foreign
this week on forward
they have this terrible accountability
trap where they're they're judged by
following the rules but when following
the rules doesn't get you the outcomes
then they you know everyone's mad about
the outcomes but we've got to remove
that accountability trap and we need
philosophy of our government that's
about removing those barriers not just
about passing new legislation I think a
lot of techies would happily join if
they could be onboarded quickly and
utilized effectively once Tech
not inside
to the time they're hooked because the
impact is so huge
[Music]
foreign
it is my pleasure and privilege to
Welcome to the podcast the founder and
CEO of code for America for a decade the
former deputy CTO of the United States
of America and the author of this
phenomenal new book recoding America why
government is failing in the digital age
and how we can do better Jennifer paulka
welcome Jennifer thank you so much
Andrew I've got to correct you from the
start though um I have not been the CEO
of code for America for three years uh
but I did found it so I passed the Baton
to a wonderful leader I know the feeling
uh so uh describe for people what code
for America is which is an organization
I admired from the get-go so we started
out with this notion that some of the
principles and practices of what we then
called Web 2.0 the participatory web the
lightweight user-centered web could help
government and we started by helping
City governments and now what is it 12
years later later we're working a lot
with States and some of the federal
government and really just trying to
make government services work for people
the way that they should and we've with
the organizations had a lot of impact
I'm really proud of the work that they
do yeah so I I started Venture for
America around the same time and I have
to say I admired an envied code for
America because what you all did was
recruit technologists and designers and
folks who wanted to make government work
better to actually work with state and
local governments around the country how
many people did you wind up enlisting uh
over the gosh now 13 years yeah I mean
our first year we had 20 fellows
um and then you know that went up and
down over the years but sort of a couple
of years in we realized that the fellows
model had a lot to offer but that to
sustain this work we really needed to
have a large full-time staff and that's
where we are today and instead of just
doing a a year-long fellowship with
people though it has been fantastic
getting Tech Talent interested in
government and we've come so so far on
that
um you know now the organization is
about 200 people full-time not you know
not taking just a fellowship year but
you know working over many years with
governments on things like automatic
records clearance or making government
services like Snap and Medicaid much
much easier to access and so it's been
hundreds of people now but through lots
of different mechanisms yeah and then
you wound up in the mothership itself in
Washington DC in the giant office across
the street though connected to the White
House as Deputy CTO uh how was your
experience in DC and what I love about
your track record Jennifer is that you
you essentially walk the walk like no
one else did like you and I know dozens
of people in Silicon Valley who are like
yeah why doesn't government just work
better but most of them as you detail in
your book haven't really invested their
own energies and trying to make a
government work better they just have
sort of taken for granted that
government bad at Tech
um tech companies good at Tech and
that's just the way of the world and you
said wait a minute there's so much
impact to be had in the public sector if
you can improve these Services as a
matter of fact you would touch Millions
more Americans in ways that are
fundamental like how they get their uh
their veterans benefits how they get
their their food stamps and so uh you
went straight to the source uh in DC as
the deputy CTO you worked with the CTO
you described that there was something
of a dark time in uh in the technology
leadership of the country because there
was no CTO until Obama arrived on the
scene
um I I actually met with the first CTO
in DC when I was running Venture for
America and then you worked with I want
to say the second or third Todd Park
um yeah
the second so and I met Todd and he's a
Powerhouse and awesome and it seems like
he did some really good persuading to
get you to to join him in DC
yeah he did
um it was funny you're absolutely right
there's something you get out of working
on the inside that you just don't get
um trying to help from the outside as
much as I I do value people trying to
help government from the outside and
many many people do when when Todd asked
me to come it was very impractical for
me code for America was just a few years
old and I was very dedicated to it I
also had a kid lived on the west coast
um ultimately you know I felt like I was
going to be a bit of a hypocrite if I
was encouraging all of these other
people to go work in government and in
fact working side by side with these
fellows who are giving a year in
government and then I wouldn't do it
myself
um that was ultimately what convinced me
though I have to say Todd is by far the
best recruiter I think I've ever met in
my life and and he he really really made
it uh sort of uh impossible for me to
say no
but my big regret only is that I
couldn't stay longer I do think that you
know when people are going into
government for a year they get a taste
of it but the real impact you know
continues
um over the years and I have uh enormous
respect for people who go into
government and stay I mean the hero of
the book really is a woman named Yadira
Sanchez she doesn't come in until
chapter 10 but
um she's been at the centers for
Medicare and Medicaid services her whole
career and I think you know she's an
enormous change agent so I I'm proud of
people like me who came in for a short
time but I'm also really enamored of
those public servants who who give it
their all and stay for a really long
time and make long-term sustainable
change because that is really really
what we need you know so you showed up
at a pivotal time in uh American Tech
History I suppose which was around the
time that healthcare.gov blew up or yeah
I mean not blew up but we all remember I
mean you know they rolled out over
Obamacare and then the website collapsed
on day one and no one could use it and
then everyone was so mad uh and uh you
were part of the team that was tasked
with trying to turn it around in real
time uh and that the lessons from that
are really interesting I can't wait to
dig into the themes of this book but
just explain to the average Americans
the average American thinks to
themselves how the heck can you have
such an epic fail
of a website and meanwhile that from
from your explanation the inner workings
um a lot of that stuff is actually very
predictable and repeats itself in
different contexts it sure does um you
know
when the pandemic hit and everyone was
surprised that we couldn't deliver
unemployment insurance in many states or
at least many people got stuck in
backlogs um nobody should have been
surprised if you're looking at how these
things are built and delivered how
they're maintained our whole approach to
government Tech technology I think it
should not have been surprising to
anybody and certainly the lessons of
healthcare.gov are applicable there I
didn't really help rescue the site I was
trying to stand up what was called
United States digital service it's still
around it's still
um really kicking butt doing great work
um and so a bunch of my colleagues and
my boss were working on the
healthcare.gov rescue
um you know it's really this whole
approach that we have to technology in
government we believe that there's some
way to objectively know all of the
possible requirements that need to be
fulfilled and then we try to hand that
entire mess over to a vendor and have
them just fulfill requirements but you
know fulfilling requirements first of
all is not setting priorities it's just
saying do it all which very rarely Works
uh and it's not
really requirements are very specific
things they don't always add up to
something that actually works and as my
friend and colleague Marina Nitza says
there's never a requirement that says
the thing should work so
in the case of healthcare.gov it was you
know a big visible uh we'll call it a
failure probably a more generous thing
to call it would be a rocky start
because it did quite well at the end of
that open enrollment period we enrolled
more people than we even thought
possible before the failure of the site
but with that really Rocky start of
course lots of attention and lots of
people upset about things you know but
you really often have things that don't
get that kind of attention but also
still just really don't work because
they're built to fit these very specific
requirements and not really you know
they're not really subject to the
scrutiny of does this thing work for the
users who are supposed to use it and we
need a really fundamental shift and how
we think about and approach this
technology if we want to stop having
failures like healthcare.gov like the
things that have happened at the VA like
the unemployment insurance backlogs I
mean we're going to continue to have
these unless we have that kind of change
foreign
I am so pumped that the last election is
coming out September 12th the political
thriller by yours truly and Stephen
Marsh the author of the next civil war
will be in stores everywhere but you can
buy your copy right now at
andrewyang.com order now and be the
first on the Block to know how the next
election turns out it has all the twists
and turns will it be the last election
let's hope not Andrew yang.com for the
last election buy it today thank you
love you all
[Music]
yeah and it's what most Americans want I
mean I think your book is so important
because it actually
diagnoses a set of problems that most
Americans have gotten very frustrated by
and then it's fed into an Institutional
mistrust and even uh I think a loss of
faith in various institutions or uh are
our government's ability to get things
done and and evolve so you mentioned the
VA you had some fascinating stories from
the VA
um and the most compelling thing I think
most of us would understand by the way
when I ran for president I met hundreds
of veterans who would uh tell me
terrible things about what was happening
with the VA or not happening whether it
be like hey I've been waiting on hip
surgery for four years and I can't get a
straight answer and you know it's like
really really depressing heartbreaking
stuff that I would hear every day on the
trail
um so you told the story of a veteran
named Dominic who uh tried to submit
requests for Karen the VA form and just
couldn't do it and he he had the this
video of himself just not being able to
do it and then you managed to get this
video in front of a senior administrator
there who just looked at it and said
okay this is totally unacceptable
um now the VA form uh fulfilled its
technical requirements those technical
requirements were kind of bizarre like I
think it had the music Internet Explorer
or something very specific uh and and
then when you said look uh like we
should probably make this form usable
for the average veteran
um with the the video from uh from
Dominic the change got made then all of
a sudden the users on the Forum shot up
something like tenfold because all of a
sudden the form was submittable and
usable and then the folks within the VA
were saying like change back to the old
form because we're not used to this kind
of volume yeah it's very unfortunate
response but uh the team that worked on
this got over that and it really became
the impetus for and enormous change
that's been going on at the VA now since
really since that time which was 2014.
so this has been a trajectory that I
think everybody at the VA can be very
proud of it is not that everything's
fixed but that realization that they had
to look outside you know the walls of
the building and see what was actually
happening for users for the veterans who
were trying to get benefits not what it
looked like on paper inside the building
has has been
um an enormous transformation yeah in in
that case
um uh again Marina Nitza and her team
Emily tavularis and Marianne Brody you
know what they found was that the
computers inside the building were set
up to use a particular combination of
Internet Explorer and Adobe Reader but
it had to be a specific version of each
of those both of them outdated
and if you were that's what that form
had been built to load on so if you were
outside the building the chances that
you have that specific combination of
those two pieces of software on your
computer was almost zero so it didn't
work for you but because it worked for
everybody inside the building they could
not see the problem and when they went
and looked at the paperwork the
paperwork said the vendor completed all
the requirements the form works fine
there's nothing we can do about this and
that's what they were told this this
wonderful team over and over again until
they brought the video of Dominic and
put it in front of the deputy secretary
and said you must watch this
and seeing what was actually happening
with this guy who is just you know a
heart of a heartbreaking narrator of
this and very funny very kind and of
course you know a bit sharp tongued
because he he really was getting screwed
um that's when everything changed and
and it's been it's been so lovely to see
the VA get better and better every year
you mentioned before the unemployment
benefits you were actually brought in to
help California uh during its covid
response
um and you told this very interesting
story so you're there trying to speed up
the response there's a backlog of claims
and then the public officials very
um proudly said look we're hiring
hundreds of new people to process claims
um but because of the esoteric nature of
the way that claims were processed a new
person didn't actually have the ability
to help process claims immediately
because it's a pretty arcane process
there was a joke saying that made maybe
it takes 17 years to become somewhat
expert in the process of having a new
hire may or may not do the trick and so
what was happening was that experienced
tires instead of clearing the backlog
we're training new hires and actually
slowing the pace down and so you were
trying to make the case to folks look
hey guys uh like this isn't a hiring
thing
like getting more people actually isn't
solving this particular
immediate bottleneck you know solving
the bottleneck would look a little
different and you had a quote that I
thought was maybe the most accurate
thing ever which is that and let's see
if I can read this to get it right it
was
when a system fails to deliver it's not
that the people within it are stupid or
evil it's that there are incentives in
play that are not evident from the
outside of that system and I I thought
that was the best explanation I had seen
for why so many of these things that
seem irrational from the outside are
perfectly rational to those on the
inside 100 I think every
I prefer 13 years and
I encounter so many folks who are upset
about government in general upset about
government Service delivery and it's
easy to ascribe sort of you know
negative intentions or incompetence to
the people doing it and that is so
rarely what I've been found you know
what I found working inside the old
adage you know it's the system not the
people is really really true you you
called it a joke you know that this guy
had been here 17 years and was still new
it wasn't a joke Andrew like he was
literally saying that the system that
they use to deliver benefits to the
people of California is so complicated
so abstruse so complex
that 17 years of working there he still
felt like he was learning it and he said
the folks who actually know how this
work have been here 25 years or more and
that's another reason I wrote the book
was that it's so easy to look at the
technology that government uses to
deliver these systems and say oh that's
bad they must have bad programmers they
must hire bad companies when you really
peel back the layers and look what's
going on there
it would be very hard for technology to
be delivering that well there's a lot to
say about how government builds and buys
technology that whole requirements issue
is a big part of it and there are many
others but when you look at something
like unemployment insurance there are
layers of technology that go back to the
80s and we've had sort of a new layer of
Technology added every decade
essentially since then yeah yeah
archeology I thought of it as like rings
in a tree yeah
um but it's you know these things have
just sort of been left there and then
they try to add on to it but there's not
a lot of backwards compatibility that
happens and you sort of create new
systems instead of refreshing the old
one and that is a problem I give it you
know I give you that and that's what we
as as Citizens see
but think about unemployment insurance
there are layers of accumulated policy
that in that case go back to the 1935
Social Security Act
and nobody ever looks at the backward
compatibility of the policy and process
that's accrued and you know really when
I when I saw that and I heard this guy
say you know I'm still learning after 17
years because it's so complicated I
really thought about the way that these
policies come down in sort of a memo
changing the old one and another memo
changing that one and this came from the
executive branch that came from the
judicial branch this came from the
federal DOL that came from the state
legislature it kind of Falls and just
sits there and has to be you know
learned for so so many years that it is
impossible to deliver these services not
just because the technology hasn't been
built well but because the people who
create our laws and policies
our elected leaders always add and they
never subtract and there's very little
attempt made to go back and sort of
rationalize and simplify those 90 some
you know it's almost 90 years of policy
accumulation and craft in unemployment
insurance and that's true everywhere so
I called it recoding America you know
because it's not the code that matters
it's like the the legal code that runs
America it sits underneath that and that
we need to look at if we're going to
have the computer code work
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn is
like not paying attention to the safety
demonstration on a flight most of the
time you'll probably be fine but what if
one day that weird yellow mask drops
down from overhead and you have no idea
what to do it's better to be safe than
sorry that's why I recommend using
expressvpn the network that's used by
high-end corporations for their remote
workers so that everything they do is
hacker proof Anonymous and verified I
like expressvpn because it's easy to use
one click and you're done and you can
access content that you might not be
able to see otherwise from Europe on
Netflix and other providers secure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com Yang that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang and you can get an extra
three months free
expressvpn.com yang
thank you
yeah and so you had so many important
ideas in this book uh one is that the
mechanical or implementation is thought
of as being kind of subordinate uh or
lesser than the policy making apparatus
and you think about the folks in DC what
is it it's a think tank it's like hey
like we should be doing this policy we
should be doing that policy and then uh
actually delivering that policy to the
American people I thought it was like oh
no that's someone else's problem it's
like not not a big deal or you know it
it's for the lessers to figure out
delivery and then but you said look for
most Americans the delivery is a policy
or the website is the policy it is
that's I mean has any of us read the tax
code lately no but we pay our taxes and
that is how we experience the tax code
it's this you know it's also true of
people getting social benefits like snap
um you don't go read the eligibility
rules you you don't go you know read
this now okay and that's how you find
out and I think that's true of so many
things but that's the delivery apparatus
the people who do delivery is not valued
it's considered sort of yeah I mean I
hate to say it but second class work in
government and so and it's not just that
second class work and sort of there's
not attention paid to it we actually
pour enormous resources into it
I think what it is is that we try to
pretend that there's no judgment
required in it it's just something that
people can take orders to do they're
going to do exactly what somebody above
them has said to do and they should not
um express any creativity or judgment or
create priorities that's why I hear from
teams all the time anyone who knows like
if you design even like a basic web page
you have to make a dozen judgments
probably 100 judgments no not even a
dozen and what are those judgments
supposed to be made on they're supposed
to be made by what is going to work for
the person who's going to use the
website but we try to take the person
who's going to use the website and out
of it what we tell people who do
delivery and government to look at is a
whole big set of requirements that have
come down from inside the bureaucracy
that's why we talk about meeting
government needs instead of meeting user
needs now I know we're going to need to
meet government needs but it's about
what comes first the user needs need to
come first and then we fit in in you
know meeting some of these compliance
requirements all these government needs
but that's the part of the shift that
needs to happen if we're going to have
these things work yeah you coined
something called Burns Law which I found
endlessly entertaining but also I'm sure
totally accurate which was that most of
these government projects could be done
for 10 of the cost with 85 percent of
the utility uh and and a lot of the
frustration a lot of Americans have is
that like you said we actually pour
tremendous resources into these things
we're like dumping hundreds of millions
of dollars sometimes billions of dollars
you quote one state I.T director who was
talking about this Mega project and you
said I don't think that Mega projects
going to uh succeed because of the way
they were designing it and she was like
you think that's new news to me the last
seven big IT projects in the state have
all failed you know like success would
be actually unusual in large part
because uh they have this waterfall
requirements first process where they
kick off by saying okay what does this
thing need to do then they have years
and years of uh of in some cases uh like
a bake off where they determine which
Mega vendor is going to to supply this
meanwhile the way most of us would do
things in business would be okay uh
let's try and get something that
fulfills some proportion of our needs
out
um pretty quickly at let's say 10 of the
cost and uh then you would iterate
because you would see after you launch
it you're like oh this thing doesn't
work this thing does work we didn't
anticipate that and then you wind up uh
tweaking and calibrating so the the
contrast really is between what's
considered the waterfall design process
which is what it seems most government
contracts uh use versus agile software
development which frankly when most
people now read about agile software
development at least for me I just think
that's just what the process is
um maybe it's just because of the people
I hang out with
um but for Lay people could you help um
I I suppose I I just gave it my best but
could you help uh distinguish between
those two approaches to product
development yeah so you know waterfall
software development is basically the
idea that you're going to have these
stages uh you're going to develop
requirements you're going to do a design
you're going to do a build you're going
to do tests and at each of those stages
you don't go back they happen
sequentially and and there's no going
back so like when you've developed
requirements you don't you don't return
to them later they're locked in even if
the thing takes 14 years so you may have
locked them in 10 years ago you still
have to deliver on those requirements
which is not how the world Works uh it
certainly doesn't work that way in
government where you have laws changing
you have guidance changing you have
different you know all these things are
changing all the time in contrast agile
software development says the thing that
matters most is not that process it's
it's understanding the needs of your
users and iteratively meeting them and
that means your requirements are
absolutely going to change because
you're going to learn you're going to
learn what your people you know can use
what works for them uh and it accepts
that we live in a world that changes
quickly today you know my point in the
book is that it's really for me I mean I
come from the software world not
technical but you know I've spent my
time in the software world and so it's a
metaphor that works for me but it is a
metaphor
because that idea of of the waterfall in
which you know the the thing that
happens third always happens third and
you never go back up the waterfall
that's the key thing about waterfall is
that the water only flows one way it's
from you know the the powerful people
who make decisions to the low-level
people who Implement and don't get a
voice in it and and agile says you know
we actually need to be hearing from
those people it's more like a loop so
you gonna you know try this thing and
then you um try it with users you learn
it's a build measure learn cycle but
it's a metaphor for how government works
and government culture where the people
who are actually doing the work on the
ground they can't go back to Congress
and say hey I know you wanted us to do X
but really if we do it in that way we're
going to have all these perverse effects
so how about we do this instead and
Congress goes oh sure like do that that
just doesn't happen because it's a
waterfall but we could think differently
about it we could say actually part of
the way our government needs to work is
to listen to the people doing the
implementation and by the way that means
listening to the people
that they're working with which are our
users which means the American public
which is like what we were founded on a
government for and by and of the people
I mean agile software development is
patriotic agile
culture agile you know government itself
is patriotic is is you know very I think
deeply rooted in the ideas of America
but we've got to change not the software
development I mean sure the software
development but we've got to change
fundamentally how people in the system
behave probably starting at the top with
legislators and other elected leaders
saying I have to care as much about the
implementation and the impact of my laws
that I sponsor or vote for as I do about
the actual words that get written on a
page and get passed through this you
know legislative process but you know I
go and visit legislators and they are
not thinking that way yet or very very
few of them are and I think that's the
that's going to be the job of the
American public here is to re-educate
our leaders about what we want do we
want words on a page or do we want the
actual impact of those laws well then we
need to hold our our elected leaders
accountable in some very different ways
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you
yeah that that is the dream that is the
vision uh Jennifer where you have a
dashboard on the walls of Congress and
it doesn't have whatever policy words it
has outcomes it has like hey like you
know the kids learning like people
getting food uh Health outcomes getting
better or worse uh you know like like
various things that you could actually
hold yourself accountable to uh and and
that's the fundamental disconnect right
now like you said it's like look
um I'm gonna argue my policy you're
gonna argue your policy and then none of
us have to actually follow up to see
whether whether uh the reality on the
ground changed unfortunately for a lot
of Americans they feel that distance and
they feel this top-down nature of
government and it's making people
increasingly frustrated
um one of the fascinating elements that
you put uh toward the back of the book
was that
um there was an oracle executive who
then writes a letter saying look look
government should not be in the tech
business
you you should not have technologists
making these kinds of evaluations you
should just stick to procurement that's
what you're good at now coincidentally
um uh Oracle happens to sell a lot of uh
software to the government the the
government and there was one story that
really rang true for me which is that
you were talking to a tech friend of
yours who's negotiating Oracle contracts
and Oracle quoted him 17 million and he
said 1 million and then uh you said
where did it wind up and he said 1.5
[Laughter]
close
um but you can very easily imagine a
government saying what this thing cost
17 million it's Oracle and be like I
guess that's what it costs maybe we'll
get a great deal and get it down to 16.
and that would be one of the many
benefits of actually integrating
Technologies into the process where
they'd be able to
get better value for the government yeah
I mean my friend happens to be highly
Technical and a very good negotiator but
almost none of those negotiations end up
where it did with my friend I mean uh
that company gets a lot of money
um because there's this huge as
asymmetry in the in the technical
know-how between the vendors and the and
and government folks and that's you know
that's an own goal as they say like we
could just decide that their technical
talents and uh leadership in government
is a high priority and that we need you
know more people actually understand the
technology than the people you know
negotiating the con you know who
understand just the really really
complicated procurement roles we need to
probably make our procurement rules a
little bit less complex but that's a
whole other story
um yeah this is a choice we make
um to you know to shoot ourselves in the
foot when it comes to government Service
delivery and um the you know I don't
really blame Oracle they're a profit
driven company and they're going to do
what they think is going to get them the
most profit but I do blame those of us
who say oh let's believe oracle's story
because it's not the right narrative the
right narrative is we can do this well
um the highest and best use of technical
talent in our country is in government
making government work better not just
Service delivery but think about things
like
you know the CDC needs you know uh needs
people to do work on the data structures
that make it so far hard for our states
and municipalities to share data with
the federal government in a pandemic you
know that's you know is that like a Snap
application no but it's an incredibly
important piece of work that the best
talent in our country should be focused
on because we you know we know we're
going to have these these crises again
and we need to be better prepared yeah I
mean you can touch a lot of people's
lives you know you improve that snap
form I mean what was the percentage of
Californians who were eligible who
weren't getting it it was like 43 I mean
that was probably yeah millions of of
families you know I I meet people all
the time now like when I started code
for America back in 2010 I was
definitely surprised at the time how
many Tech folks wanted to work in
government like everyone I I would tell
people I'm going to start this program
they'd be like No One's Gonna apply for
that tech people don't want to work in
government but we had 525 people for 20
slots the first year but now know like
it's even more people and I think
because they've had a chance to see how
much impact you can have whether it's
coveted response or you know helping the
US government help Ukraine or SNAP
benefits like once tech people get a
taste of doing Tech in government and
design people and and people not inside
Tech most of the time they're hooked
because the impact is so huge and I it's
it's a it's a big misunderstanding that
people think that tech people don't want
to go into government in fact what we
really need is government to get better
at hiring processes so we can hire and
onboard these people yeah yeah I think a
lot of techies would happily join if
they uh could be onboarded quickly and
utilized effectively I think that's a
lot of like a lot of the concern so the
US digital service usds has been a major
success story and has already paid for
itself something like 20 fold can you
update us on what's going on with this
crack Squad of techies who hang out in
DC and try and get stuff done like what
what's it up to when did it get started
I actually write about the usds and and
forward because I admire it so much it's
a great institution
um uh it's this modeled after the
government digital service in the UK
um though you know it's it's different
in many ways because we're two different
governments with different sets of
authorities and structures
um so now it's a couple hundred folks
it's within the Office of Management and
budget
um I could talk a little bit about the
challenges of getting it set up but you
know where it is today I think it is
best actually
um when it's helping agencies do their
work better so it's not really set up to
do things for agencies because that's
only going to help in the very short
term in fact this is in its DNA like I
was at the White House trying to set up
usds1 healthcare.gov failed and yes um
my boss brought in a team that helped
CMS the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid services get the site back up
but a lot of the end of the book is
really the story of the aftermath of
that I guess aftermath sounds like a bad
word but I mean the good aftermath of
that in which CMS really realizes that
this approach that Todd Park and others
brought at that time this user-centered
Agile development
um that they could do it themselves and
the transformation that CMS has been
going through to be a fantastic leader
in agile and and a fantastic
service you know provider and the real
successes that they've had since then
which don't rely on the usds anymore
they do it themselves and I think that's
true at the VA it's true all over HHS
it's been true
um in many departments uh it's true at
USCIS citizenship and Immigration
Services
and some of their projects aren't even
things like Service delivery you know
um the refugee program or
um the VA Healthcare but they are the
core functions that government needs to
do so for instance uh there's login.gov
like every agency can use this tool it's
actually you know a project of GSA but
was started as a collaboration between
GSA and usds and then there's things
like hiring which I mentioned is such a
big problem well for about four years
now usds has been working with the
office of personnel management on a
project called smiqua please uh forgive
me for that acronym uh not not my fault
but still
um still something a great project with
not a great name but it stands for
subject matter expert qualifying
assessments which is basically designed
to tackle the problem that a hiring
takes way too long but also that we
don't actually assess people for their
skills 90
of open to the public job announcements
in government rely on a self-assessment
and a resume review I don't know about
that one yeah is designed to say no we
can do this if I'm hiring a programmer
that we need to assess those candidates
based on actual uh you know assessments
by real programmers if it's you know and
they've created a process that allows
that to happen under existing law policy
and regulation we get far better
candidates
um and we hire the right person and we
hire them much faster and that you know
you wouldn't think usds as digital in
the name would be working on things like
hiring but their process redesign skills
are amazing their ability to do what we
call bureaucracy hacking is amazing
their ability to partner with places
like OPM is amazing and it's they're
really well used when they work fun
stuff that's going to touch every single
agency like every digital leader I know
in government says hiring is their
biggest problem and sneaka is one way to
fix that so I think they're just really
great when they're a support mechanism
for making all of government better but
through the agencies and the agencies
can take credit for it and take pride in
that work
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
if you're a regular listener you know
that I am a mattress guy and that I
believe investing in your mattress is
one of the smartest savviest things you
can do to be happier healthier more
energized more able to live your life
it's why I'm so pumped to recommend
Helix sleep because they are the
mattress company that will send a
customized mattress to you based upon
your sleep preferences risk-free made in
the USA number one mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine and there is a
special sale for Labor Day the best
discount I have ever seen them offer 25
off that's right Helix is offering 25
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners in honor of
Labor Day probably because a lot of you
are moving need a mattress go to
helixsleep.com Yang and use code Helix
partner 25 this is their best offer yet
and it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now
yeah so I think you should give rise to
a movement Jennifer I'm going to give
you a terrible acronym for it right now
it's uh Maguire which is make government
work again
totally fine
my big question for you so I'm a huge
believer in what you've laid out in this
book I think there's a desperate need to
recode America and make it so that we're
actually modern
um you talk about how look
investing in 21st century State capacity
is not something that uh there is any
political incentive around meanwhile I
think that this is the definition of
where we need to go as quickly as
possible because the problems are
getting worse in Harry our institutional
trust is going lower and lower and so
the only way to turn it around is to be
like look guys we will actually deliver
for you we will be you know accountable
transparent to you really genuinely
um so let's imagine uh that I was
President of the United States uh and
you and you were and you were to come in
and say okay Andrew here are like the
three things that we need to do that's
going to make agile software development
more normal clear up some of the crazy
thickets of rules and rigs so that a
group gets defined nine different ways
uh in in the legal code which thus makes
building a you know website for it
impossible because one of the things
that you said that I I that struck me as
true having met with uh you know I guess
the first two ctOS which is like the
ctOS of the US laid out really
intelligent policies but then those
intelligent policies didn't necessarily
get adopted by all the other agency
heads because guess what you know like
if you're another agency head you're
like well like what's this you know the
ctOS like a peer of mine over there like
it's not you know he's like two or three
levels removed from the president which
sounds senior but then I'm only one
level removed from the president so but
I don't really need to listen to it
necessarily by the way not only did I I
run for president I also even said down
the stretch I was like look
I think there should be a new secretary
of Technology uh and I think that you
should just make account names and I
hinted not so suddenly that I was like
and if this were to exist you know like
I'd be game for the job though I dare
say
um you'd be a better fit for it than me
but I was willing to to actually say
like look I would do this thing in part
because I was concerned about Ai and
thought that uh someone would need to
get out there and uh and actually try
and interface with the the AI companies
um in a way that was uh more Nimble and
um up to date as opposed to sort of wait
for it to turn through agencies anyway
um you're still needed Andrew well
thanks Jennifer you too
um so but but so I I now am a huge
believer in Maguire or the rise of the
Mechanicals or whatever we're gonna call
this thing
um but uh and you end the book with
something of an Earnest call being like
look like part of this stuff is like
actually getting in there uh applying
your energies there are a lot of Heroes
Within These bureaucracies and
organizations like we have to kind of
free them to be able to to do the right
thing
um but it did get my mind racing too
okay let's say that I was actually in
that seat like how could we clear the
path for people to be able to do the
right thing
you mean to go into government or or
like if it's because one of the things
that I totally agree with you on is that
we have this Byzantine crazy layer of
code legal code that we just keep adding
things to uh and then and you say look
even if I were to transpose this into
the cloud it's still a mess like I just
took like a like a bale of
um that would have made me think of is
like extension cords you find in a
drawer it's like you open yeah you're
like hey I want to take this to the
cloud it's like well it still looks like
a freaking extension cord ball exactly
yeah I mean I think we kind of need to
start moving the Overton windows so to
speak
um
you know you think it take unemployment
insurance for example like there was
some talk during the pandemic of maybe
we need to federalize this program
which is one you know one sort of major
shock to the system that could change
things but you know what I didn't hear
was we need to dramatically simplify
this I mean really how hard is it right
like we're going to create some
eligibility rules and then some benefit
rules and there's got to be some rules
for adjudication but it's not 25 years
of learning that you know it's not it
shouldn't be so complicated it takes 25
years to learn
um I think there are places where we
need to be able to say
we have to zero base this program like
let's go throw it all out and design a
program that would work for 2024 and
2025.
we never even say that it's just like
not in the realm of possibility
um I think a lot of what we need to do
is just in a weird way kind of when we
work in government we get trained to ask
for very little because it's so hard to
get even the tiniest thing done like oh
I made a hire this year I'm really proud
of myself and we need to ask for more
but like we as the public need to ask
for more on behalf of public servants
and by more I mean Bolder things like
let's just start over with unemployment
insurance how should it work can it be
Federal you know can it be administered
by the states does it need to be
federalized
um and I think that's just true of a lot
of things and until we put that out as a
possibility we're not going to get
anywhere near it I realize that it's a
pipe dream with all of this maybe it's
not a pipe dream that's the point
Jennifer is that we we have to we we
have to get the stuff on the table uh
and and when I was running for president
I was like look guys you know like I
just want to make something that would
actually help you and it and has as
little Administration as possible in the
form of like universality like screw it
and then people look at that and be like
hey is that a pipe dream I'd be like
well shoot
we have to make a move like that at some
point because trying to push things
through the thicket and then during
covid when uh we started sending our
relief checks to people we did use the
IRS it was a highly highly imperfect
because the IRS it was not designed for
that
um but still uh you know tens even
hundreds of millions of Americans got
checks or transfers and then I gotta
tell you my phone is ringing off the
hook for like the entire month and uh
and anytime I went on the street people
would thank me even though I you know
like I mean I did Lobby for it and I did
hire lobbyists
so I guess I maybe like I did deserve
that thank you a little bit but um but
there were but there were folks that you
know thought that you know like I'd
essentially uh like pushed that idea so
when you say it's a pipe dream like I
think it's the pipe dream that we need
to put out there it's like we should
just say like how can we simplify these
programs to make them easy and
delightful and right now they're so
punitive where it's like it seems like
essentially I'm going to treat you like
a criminal to make sure that you don't
get any extra money
[Laughter]
terrible stories is about like the 212
question application for uh I think it
was food stamps or or the example where
you get asked whether you own a burial
plot uh in your application for benefits
because of area plots an asset it turns
out it is worth money and then you wound
up sitting across the table from the guy
who's like oh yeah I wrote that because
they when the Congress wanted to know
what your assets were and a pair of
plots an asset meanwhile that like two
of us are just like that is absolutely
insane like if you happen to own a
burial plot
like who cares it so far is your
eligibility for you know for for food
stamps is concerned yeah but that was
really learning you know interesting
learning moment for me realizing that
the guy who had put that in there which
I thought was like really punitive he
was just trying to do a good job like he
just thought
that you know his job was to assess all
the assets you know and he and that's
what Congress asked him to do so he
wouldn't be as thorough as possible and
it was like the extra credit it's like
the nerd and I was a nerd yeah
[Laughter]
yeah but you know to that point though
about like you know it's a pipe dream or
not you know I tell the story in the
book in the sort of the beginning and
the very end about automatic records
clearance so you have typically a felony
for marijuana marijuana is no longer a
crime in your state so the felony should
be expunged but there was a year-long
incredibly burdensome complicated
paperwork and showing up in court
process that you had to go through so
nobody got through it I mean literally
almost nobody was getting through it and
you know we were we kept looking at ways
to streamline the that process to make
it easier but there were a couple
Advocates out there saying there
shouldn't be a process at all make it
automatic and a lot of other people
saying oh that's a pipe dream that'll
never happen it can't be automatic and
then we you know went and worked with
the uh the district attorney in San
Francisco George gascon and his his
chief
um Christine uh Soto DeBerry and we're
like wait we can these are just records
in a database let's just use an
algorithm very simple algorithm to find
all the eligible records and then clear
them all at once and something that had
seemed like a pipe dream was now a
reality and now tons of states are doing
this automatic records
and it's a great example of zero tasting
it's not like how do we adjust a little
on the margins but how do we make this
crap a little less crappy it's like no
you know fundamentally rethink it like
yeah totally and rethink it for a
digital era like yes there needed to be
a petition form back in the 50s when
everything was on paper but that's
simply unnecessary at all today
yes
zero base it that sounds so so badass
too Jennifer it's better than mcgua or
rise of the Mechanicals zero zero basic
most of the times we're not doing that
and it is worth making it a little bit
better every day and I'm okay with that
too but I want to keep putting that you
know that that magua Vision uh and this
that zero-based vision and the sort of
transformational change out on the table
it needs to be there Jennifer because
we're running out of time honestly I
mean like you know we we can't just keep
on inching along I mean things are
disintegrating around us really quick
um I'm going to close on something that
I thought was really fascinating and I
thought and this is like again why I
admire
um this book so so much so here's like
the in Kuwait ideological argument
people are having
um so so number one is that like
conservatives are like hey government
doesn't work starve at starbit um uh bad
money bad money
um and then you're like well you know
like that that doesn't actually make a
whole lot of sense in a lot of contexts
because because if you try and do that
like sometimes you just end up like
costing yourself more money like you got
rid of the office of Technology
assessment which cost us like what like
a few like tens of millions and we
probably lost tens of billions then
like uh in in
um even sensible procurement as one
example and then on the other side uh
Ezra Klein describes the liberal
critique as a small cramped legalistic
uh professional where it's just like
rules rules rules rules rules rules
rules will save us and we're going to
sue anyone who tries to do anything
because that that's like the mechanism
that we've found to uh to to stop the
bad guys where the bad guys are but in
in some cases the bad guys the
government is trying to do something and
so then you're then your ability to do
something uh goes out the window because
you'll just be subject to lawsuits
California is particularly guilty of
this the thing that frustrates me so
much right now and your book like
illustrates us over and over again is
like is that the dumbness of the
conversations we have which is you know
we need we need more money you know what
we need we need less money it's like no
no we just actually need that works
like you know and if I spent 10 of what
I'm spending now and get 85 of value
like I would be pumped it was supposed
to be pumped the problem is right now
we're spending 100 and getting 10 of the
value and then we're like arguing and be
like you know why you know why you're
mad it's like we needed more money it's
like did you really need more money
well you probably didn't need more money
and the average American senses this
they're pissed off because they're like
you are not using my money effectively I
I can sense that and then that gives
rise to like legitimate uh anger
um so so the the thing that I want to
say Maguire or rise of the Mechanicals
is it's like the actual true middle
ground it's like you know you you don't
necessarily want I mean like I can say
like in some domains you probably do
want smaller government but in in some
domains you probably want government
that just does its job better like
actually
delivers and and then on the the liberal
side it's like look guys like you can
point at the rule book uh like all day
long but if we can't get stuff done for
people what's the point you know what I
mean like like you're using the the the
code as an excuse not to deliver and
then if if someone does try and deliver
by the way and this is the cage that
we've put the government employees in
because they're like oh I can't do it
because of rules right they're stuck
they have this terrible accountability
trap where they're they're judged by
following the rules uh but when
following the rules doesn't get you the
outcomes then they you know everyone's
mad about them about the outcomes but
we've got to remove that accountability
trap and we need uh sort of philosophy
of our government that's about removing
those barriers not just about passing
new legislation like I think after chips
and infrastructure and Ira like three
gigantic bills passed if we had the
right culture in government all of DC
would have been like okay everybody is
now focused on implementation that
implementation means removing things not
adding them like freeing us to get the
thing done not layering a bunch more
rules on something so that it's be
harder to get it done but instead we
just sort of assume that implementation
will happen and move on to you know new
legislative fights or new policy fights
and it's like we just swallowed three
elephants let's digest them
but we don't even think that way you
know I talked to people who are looking
at for example the need to have a bunch
of mechanics go out uh to retrofit
things for green energy and it's like
look like that's what the bill says but
then who are the humans who are actually
going to go out and do the thing you
know it turns out we have a massive
shortage of those humans uh and so even
if you put the incentives in place like
is it going to magically get done it's
like probably not in a lot of these
areas to your point and so
um so maybe some of our energy should be
spent on actually implementing to your
point uh and maybe that I mean again I'm
still going to be groping for our
tagline here
um like uh implementation
like that's probably not that catchy
either but you're you're working on this
because I'm still struggling for the
title I do yeah uh watch Silo see if you
like the Mechanicals thing that I mean
that that show is a big hit and so like
people might dig it and it's got by by
the way this like incredible female
protagonist that you kind of remind me
of
um which is you see it and see if you
like the comparison um anyway but we'll
we'll work on this Maguire uh ryzen
Mechanicals movement but it's genuinely
what we need
um and I think we we need to go as fast
as possible like you know your your book
uh sends the correct message which is
like look guys we need to lean in we
need to like work with the with the
yadiras and the heroes within but I I am
someone who's like I don't think we have
a whole lot of time I agree I agree and
we should just tell people quickly that
in the book we talk about Mechanicals
because the British Civil Service makes
the distinction between the
intellectuals and the Mechanicals and I
think that's you know that's carried
over into our government culture as well
so it's like where are the Mechanicals
do they have a seat at the table and do
we have enough of them where are the
Mechanicals Jennifer polka
recoding America why government is
failing in the digital age and how we
can do better perhaps the best policy
book I have read this year uh
congratulations my friend and let's try
and make your vision a reality rise of
the Mechanicals rise of the implementers
rise of the Mechanicals thank you so
much Andrew it's been a delight to talk
with you
[Music]
foreign